la mer la plage les hôtels de luxe
principales stations balnéaires en
ukraine êtes aucun semble un milieu de
la guerre qui secoue le pays mais le
calme n'est ici qu'une apparence et même
à des centaines de kilomètres de la
ligne de front personne n'est à l'abri
cet hôtel frappé au petit matin par un
missile en est un bon exemple
il n' a dit vladimir habite à deux coins
de rue ils sont encore sous le choc
nous avons entendu un bruit sourd qui a
fait trembler les murs et éclater les
fenêtres de tout le quartier
explique-t-elle les voisins ne
comprennent pas pourquoi l'hôtel a été
frappé
on n'a jamais vu de soldats ici jamais
vu le moindre véhicule militaire
jure-t-elle convaincus qu'il s'agit
d'une erreur
la boîte de semaine faire juste à côté
était peut-être la cible réellement visé
ou encore le pont situé à quelques
kilomètres quoi qu'il en soit cet hôtel
est le troisième du coin bombardé en
moins d'une semaine
encore un autre épisode absurde dans une
guerre qui paraît insensé
alexei non plus ne s'explique pas cette
folie propriétaire de l'hôtel il en
inspectant les ruines encore incrédule
pour prendre la mesure de l'étendue de
la tragédie une tragédie humaine d'abord
et avant tout car sous ses décombres se
trouvait son fils sa belle fille et sa
petite-fille à simonian onishi projet de
prost au moins aussi aujourd'hui ma
famille a été détruite mon âme a été
piétinée dit-il et je ne sais pas
pourquoi
submergé par l'émotion il doit prendre
une pause avant de raconter la suite un
récit qui s'écrit dans le sang
outre les bureaux nous
voilà la pantoufle de ma petite fille
raconte ils l étaient coincés ici sous
cette dalle et la perdrait plusieurs
doigts une main et sa jambe ne tenait
que par la peau du nord caucase ont reçu
une
note
alexandra là que cinq ans elle est
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital entre la vie et
la mort à la recherche de photos pour
mieux nous la présenter alexei seront
dans sa chambre mais il ne trouve que
les jouets de filles est recouvert de
poussière et la réalité le rattrape d'un
seul coup dans ce
sens une minute on regarde le ciel bleu
et la mer et on se dit que les vielles
bonne dutil et la minute suivante on
retrouve ses enfants dans une mare de
sang et tout s'arrête
gagné jean haniquaut mostra chemins
roulants je ne souhaite pas ça à
personne ajoute-t-il il faut absolument
arrêter cette guerre ce massacre instant
des victimes
astana victime et non un cri du coeur
celui d'un grand père inconsolable
seul élément positif dans cette affaire
l'hôtel était fermé au moment de
l'impact fermé pour rénovation en
attendant une éventuelle réouverture à
la belle saison autrement en juger par
l'étendue des dommages le bilan aurait
certainement été beaucoup plus élevé ici
jean françois bélanger radio-canada
zatoka